THIS ONE IS ALSO CALLED THE
PASCAL MOON.
[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD," I'M JESSE WATTERS.
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
IF A TREE FALLS IN THE FOR REST-
IF A TREE FALLS IN THE FOR RESTI
IF A TREE FALLS IN THE FOR RESTN
IF A TREE FALLS IN THE FOR RESTT
IF A TREE FALLS IN THE FOR RESTE
FOREST AND NO ONE IS AROUND,
DOES IT MAKE A SOUND.
THE MEDIA CRITICIZES HIM BUT
THEY NECESSITY GIVE HIP CREDIT
WHEN HIS ACTIONS HAVE POSITIVE
RESULTS.
THE PRESIDENT STARTED IMPOSING
TARIFFS ON STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
>> NOW NEW TARIFFS THAT MIGHT
ULTIMATELY IGNITE A TRADE WAR.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS IGNORED THE
ADVICE OF MOST OF BUSINESS
LEADERS.
>> IF YOU ARE THINKING THIS
PRESIDENT HASN'T REALLY THOUGHT
THIS THROUGH VERY WELL?
THAT'S HOW IT HAPPENED.
JESSE: BUT THE TARIFFS WERE JUST
A BARGAINING CHIP AND THEY
WORKED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THIS WEEK WE
SECURED A WONDERFUL DEAL WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
WE HAD A DEAL THAT WAS A HORROR
SHOW.
IT WAS GOING TO PRODUCE 200,000
JOBS AND I'D DID FOR THEM.
SHE WAS RIGHT, BUT IT WAS FOR
THEM, NOT FOR US.
JESSE: SOUTH KOREA DOUBLED THE
AMOUNT OF AMERICAN CARS THEY
WILL ALLOW TO BE SOLD IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
THIS IN EXCHANGE FOR TRUMP
TEMPORARILY DROPPING THE THREAT
OF STEEL TARIFFS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
IT MARKS THE FIRST SUCCESSFUL
RENEGOTIATION OF A TRADE DEAL
FOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THAT LINE WAS BURIED AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE STORY, NOT EVEN
WORTHY OF A HEADLINE.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN TRAVELED TO
BEIJING FOR CONSTRUCTIVE TALKS
WITH HIS PUPPET MASTER.
AMERICA AND NORTH KOREA ARE NOW
HOPEFULLY ON THE CUSP OF TALKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: CERTAINLY THE
RHETORIC HAS CALMED DOWN JUST A
LITTLE BIT.
WOULD YOU SAY?
WE'LL SEE HOW IT ALL TURNS OUT.
MAYBE IT WILL BE GOOD AND MAYBE
IT WON'T.
JESSE: MORE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKER AT HOME AS A
RESULT OF TAX AND REGULATION
CUTTING.
AMERICANS APPLYING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT FELL TO THE LOWEST
RATE SINCE 1973.
REMEMBER WHAT THE MEDIA SAID THE
TRUMP TAX CUT WOULDN'T HELP THE
LITTLE GUY?
McDONALD'S JUST ANNOUNCED IT
WILL SEND $150 MILLION ON